cause they've got comatose patients so
that they wants me to post the their
workload is up a quarter and their way
of working has been turned upside down
even the morning meeting between dozens
of district nurses on shift in this part
of Mercy side is now virtual team leader
Kim has been a district nurse for nearly
40 years and says things have changed
fast it's a very different way and we
had lots of meetings in rooms but now
we're very digital and very a virtual
and it's really good I don't think we'll
ever go back but nothing can replace a
home visit to a patient whose life
depends on hands-on care district nurse
Beth is on her way to see a 77 year old
man with cancer who needs medication
through his stomach three times a day
he's just been released from hospital
where he tested positive for kovat 19
Beth isn't sure if he's still shedding
the virus so has to wear PPE have just
become like the new normal really back
in his own home Anthony's doing well but
the district nurses are also seeing
patients with and without Covey's
symptoms passing away in the community
we took of and see patients who have no
symptoms whatsoever and like they Tony
that I've just seen then he said that he
had no symptoms the only symptom he had
was a temperature which he found out
when he went into hospital many have had
critical hospital appointments cancelled
because of coronavirus adding to the
pressure on district nurses I catch Joe
on what never hit your laxative awesome
that's all 60 year old Karen has
terminal esophageal cancer and has
discovered a new lump now this code 19
come along I feel like I'm getting left
and not get no treatment and now I'm not
going to get there so I know I'm not
sure but I've got to live with that for
I've got four children and I want to
or so it's constantly on me mind that I
don't want to close my eyes because I
don't want to die in Crocs death this
health center is empty with people only
being seen at home or over the phone
hospital discharge to care in the
community has traditionally been a slow
process but coronavirus has changed that
too we've accepted more complex patients
out of our hospitals to allow our
hospitals to be to be readied and for
the coronavirus so routinely some
patients that we have seen would have
been in hospital for that long it's
about convalescence has been out of here
within the within the community
even when lockdown ends it's unlikely
caring the community will ever return to
exactly the way it was before the
outbreak of corona virus Lisa Holland
Sky News Merseyside